ils sont des trésors cachés de la lah
les yeux au pays de nosy veille les
pauvres gens je veux tu finis les poches
avec un capot de même les vieux sont
comme des mioches
comme si la vie n'était qu'un jury à la
cub
comme les bêtes à bon dieu
à
le
en attendant
il
on
ils attendent chaque jour
tout n'est bel été pour n'avoir pas
ralenti ma faim s'installer
sur le pas d'une route au soleil sans
pitié
s'il tente à main se sent tout au tout
partager via le
comme les bêtes à bon dieu
que
en attendant
et
une
le rêve est en brousse près d'un arbre
sacré quant à lui mais pas des rousses
ils sont
chanter au bal poussière d'un soir par
leurs hommes à danser danser puis boire
ces défis
à
le
comme l'ébène apprend que
la queue leu leu
en attendant
e
c'est peut-être la soif du mak au manque
de places dans métro mais je donne pas
cher de ma peau
dans ce monde en veut à boubou
apparemmment
on se croit demi dieux appartement que
de joie moi j'ai pas mon ennemi à la cud
car les bêtes à bon dieu va
la queue leu leu
en attendant à
comme les bêtes à bon dieu
que le
beaucoup en attendant
mieux